John Lewis and Waitrose staff have had
their bonuses slashed to six percent to
around three weeks salary following a
10% of water last year the partnership
said the cut was in preparation for
tougher trading conditions ahead and
came despite annual pre-tax profits
climbing by two-thirds to 488 million
pounds or so Charlie Mayfield is
chairman of the John Lewis Partnership
Charlie blooming to you now normally you
traditionally you filmed the partners
receiving the bonus announcement here's
what happened last year
[Applause]
you didn't let the cameras in this year
pretty obvious one nod I guess well
actually with the reports pecados there
was a chair a smaller chair fair enough
what we said to people in January is
that bonus was going to be significantly
down so this was not a surprise yeah of
course people are well there will be
some people who are disappointed because
everyone likes our bonus but I think
there's basically realism and
understanding about about why and we're
really focused on making sure we succeed
in the future I guess some partners will
be baffled as to why the headline
profits are up yet the bonus has come
down and though it's quite a technical
accounting issue behind the the rise in
the headline pre-tax profits isn't it
well there will be some questions but I
think there's an important point it's
more than just accounting in fact the
partnership is actually in a strong
position Waitrose and John Lewis have
performed well we've seen sales growth
and we've seen profits growth so we're
actually pleased with that but what
we're really saying is we are
anticipating that there are big changes
afoot in society in the workplace in
retail and they're all going to have a
big effect not just on us but on all
companies and essentially what we're
doing is we're saying that we're going
to retain a bit more profit this year in
order to make sure we've got the
firepower to ensure the partnership is
successful in the long run now the
partnership bonus is one of the key
reasons what a lot of people like to
work for the partnership do you worry
that you're becoming any less an
attractive employee with the reduction
like this no definitely not because you
see it's not it's only one element of
the reward and it is an important one
and of course I don't deny that but you
know one of the things we've said today
is we actually increased the pay rates
the pay for our lowest paid partners by
5% last year so effectively what we have
is the average hourly rate of pay for
our lowest paid partners is now eight
pounds 65-inch it's a it's a healthy
increase gap this is the national living
wage and we're determined to keep it
there and a part of the reason for
holding the money back from on bonus is
to make the investment we need to make
in getting the organization to the right
place and putting in place the right
innovation so we can create better jobs
in the future for better performing
partners on better pay where's this
investment going to fool them because
looking at the numbers for last year I
mean investment in the cordial know it
John Lewis stores were up investment in
Waitrose was down I think 28 percent
well the difference is that we've we've
basically cut back on our investment in
new show
but we are increasing our investment in
our existing shops and of course that's
where it affects most partners and of
course it's good news for customers so
in simple terms we're investing in the
customer and we're investing in partners
and they're their ability to offer those
customers better and better service so
for example in Waitrose we plan to reach
just about every Waitrose shop over the
next three years and spend some money on
them to improve those shops our
customers will really benefit and say
well partners and you talk about
societal changes that you've got to
prepare the business form this is mainly
the shift to online presumably well no
not particularly I mean I think in terms
of society there are lots of changes in
the way people are living their lives
and they and you know we're we're a
customer facing business so we need to
adapt our business for that but it's you
know different patterns of behavior
people living longer they're having
different needs their interests are
changing and as a company that serves
customers we need to be anticipating
that not waiting for them to arrive but
getting ahead of that but there are also
other changes such as what's happening
in retail and we're absolutely ready for
that - how worried are you about the
weaker pound on you you make reference
to it in the statement it's going to be
an uncertainty is that largely down to
sterling LED inflation so look I said in
January that the inflation was the dock
that hadn't bought I think what we can
now hear is the sort of the low rumble
of a growl but it remains uncertain I
mean there's no question if sterling
remains as weak as it is it will create
inflationary pressure the big question
is where does it land what we're doing
is working really hard to make sure that
our prices are kept but frankly the same
and they don't go up at all and both in
John Lewis and Waitrose John Lewis is
never known the undersold which means
whether the last ones to put prices up
and of course
yeah but how difficult is that in an
online environment where you're up
against people with considerably lower
overheads in some cases well so it is of
course it's challenging the UK is one of
the most competitive retail markets in
the world
and as a result actually customers
benefit from that because it means that
you know companies like us have to be
really on our game in terms of
innovation we have to keep costs tight
and work hard to capture every sale and
so it's not just all about the the
weaker pan then essentially no I mean
yeah this is this is a really
competitive market so you know we
compete with just about everybody and we
sort of enjoy that in the sense that
it's all about you know being on top of
your game but again you know the reason
we've said what we have today profits
are bonus down retaining some more money
to make sure we're successful in the
future